so good morning everyone thank you
for being with us today
before we begin i would like to take a
moment to recognize the
national day of remembrance and action
on violence against women
as you know 33 years ago
the École
Polytechnique shooting took the lives of 14 women 14 young
women who had their lives ahead of them and
in light of the news from last week
surrounding the Coalition
for Guns
I can tell you that words fail me
exploit this tragedies on the eve of
commemorations and just plain
heinous disgusting and heart
we are still waiting for an apology from them
our hearts go out to the
victims and survivors and survivors
and we will never tolerate any form
of violence against women in  Canada
and abroad by
now you have probably
all read the report 10
on specific benefits related
to covid-19 filed by the audit.  on
general this
morning first of all i would like to
thank the auditor general
and her team for
preparing this report and her recommendations
i am particularly proud to see
that her report also recognizes that
our emergency programs have
not worked well  need to tell you that these
programs have not only saved
lives but also saved our economy by
helping Canadians put bread
on the table to keep a roof
over their heads in these unprecedented times
as you know the covid-  19 was the
biggest crisis that Canada had to
manage since the Second World War
the agency was called upon to
deploy
the government's emergency economic measures in record time and
had a clear mission to bring
the most  quickly as possible money
to the Canadian and to businesses
once again I want to congratulate the
officials of the agency and
tell them how much I am  proud of their
work and the historic work they
have done
their dedication to serving Canadians
from coast to coast and just
remarkable and we owe them a lot
now although we
welcome the recommendations of the
Auditor General I can  not
ignore our disagreement with
certain conclusions of the report, more
particularly the estimate of
overpayments linked to business subsidies,
following these analyzes and verification of
the Canada emergency wage subsidy program, the agency found
that the vast majority of
canadian companies have indeed
applied for benefits in good faith the
agency continues its painstaking work
of verification and although it is too
early to comment on the
total amount of overpayments the results
so far suggest a level
of compliance  higher than that
estimated by the Auditor General, we
can therefore expect  to be in the real country
much lower than the figures that
were announced in the report
the agency continues to move forward
with its compliance and
collection activities and remains confident of
recovering the sums
I would also like to remind you that  these
companies are familiar with
agency practices and know that they are able
to get the information they
need to enforce the law to
better understand our position both
for the wage subsidy and the CERB
I would like to keep up to date
context in which we
developed them
firstly our government
determined that in the circumstances
applications based on an attestation
was not only the most
efficient and rapid way to set up
our programs but also the only way
in the context where many Canadians
came  to lose their jobs at
that time the money had to go to
their pocket without misdemeanors the status quo
was not an op  tion
and unsurprisingly adding additional parameters
and criteria would have
had the effect of delaying the launch
of benefits and we knew that
Canadians simply could
not afford to wait
our government did the right thing
and responded to the right  moment
to help them
secondly I would like to remind that
we were clear from the beginning
the eligibility for benefits was going to be
checked once the required tax data was
going to be
available if we remember correctly in
2020 the agency had  not the
tax data of 2019 allowing him for
example to confirm the income of the
people who applied for the PC moreover
the tax season had been extended
until September 30
let us also remember that at this period
the waves of covid-19 which
the anguish of Canadians
was at its height and in this context
the priority of the agency was to
meet their most
urgent needs  nts
now we have vaccines that
have and we have evolved with the
pandemic and these tax data
the agency men now
that is also why its
verification work is well underway and far from
finished until now I can tell you
confirm that the agency has issued more than
1.1 million notices of assessment in
connection with overpayments which totals
three points 2 billion dollars and
these figures continue
to climb as I speak to you
it is checks are done  out of
respect and the philosophy of the
agency people first
means that it is the agency that
the agency will never place a canadian
in a position where he must choose
between putting bread on the table or
repay
I want the message to be clear if
you have received a notice of debt it is
important to contact the agency
our agents are trained and ready to
discuss your situation to find
an agreement that will respect your
ability to pay  er
in closing, I would like to recall
that beyond the figures and
statistics indicated in the report
of the general verification of human lives
were at stake at that time
and our government never hesitated
to make the choices necessary to  help
everyone get through
this difficult period
our government has delivered and
will deliver concrete results for
all Canadians and before giving the
floor to my colleagues, I would like to
mention that the officials of
the agency are here with us  today
and are available for you if you have
more technical questions
after the press conference and
now I leave the floor to my
colleague the minister because the quattro
thank you
good morning everyone I too wish
everything  first to mark the 33rd
anniversary of the terrible attack at
the École polytechnique we
remember the victims but their
families and friends and we will
continue to do t  everything it takes
to make our country safer
for all I would also like to
highlight the important work
done by the Office of the Auditor
General and thank it for its
performance audit on vaccines against
covid 19
content of the efforts  unprecedented that
have been deployed to get covid 19
vaccines licensed and distributed
in the country I
welcome the observations of the Office
of the Auditor General
[Music]
at the start of the pandemic no one
could predict which vaccine candidate
would be effective with an application
world high our government made it
clear that we would invest
in multiple vaccine candidates
this ensured rapid access to
effective and safe vaccines against
covid Canada treeing of first free
countries in the world you are going to be
bone ministry  in the Sunder twenty
twenty the Government of Canada will
continue to ensure that the country
has a sufficient quantity of
vaccines against covid 19 while
taking important and
responsible steps to manage our
vaccine stocks an advance lunch
[Music]
thank you mega
service
the work done to obtain these
contracts to help ensure
that the greatest  is strong
vaccination in our history is
also one of the most successful
since 1999 that it is a problem not to
see an agreement on the sharing
of information said that it is urgent to
remedy so where is it blocking is it  that
it is blocking on the federal side is
it blocking on the side of several provinces
or is it blocking exactly before covid
it was blocking among other things from the point of view
of technology so technology to
allow information to be shared
but with covid 19 the  technology is
now in place so what needs to be
done now is to accelerate and
share information from the provinces
and territories to the Canadian
government  so that the
public health agency can better plan and better
use the doses of vaccines that are
available, but this is a much
broader issue we are in 2022 in Canada
our health system our
health data system is not  not a
global ranking system is a
poor ranking system compared to
many other countries in the world we
cannot use
individual health data enough to
protect safety and quality of
care so we have a lot of work  to
do including on vaccines because
in Canada for covid 19 the
vaccines committed 19 we have done
quite well and certainly compared
to very covid-19 but there is a lot
of other information on other
vaccines that  'we do not currently have in
the Canadian government what prevents us
from helping the provinces and
territories to do a better job
in terms of vaccination are we
talking about are we talking about the same  my
data same data sharing as in
the case of health transfers you
talked about the discussions on this when
you met with your
provincial-territorial counterparts where are we
really talking about the same thing then where
may pose other problems
beyond vaccines but it's not
the same thing
vaccines treatments drugs
equipment clinical techniques
all that in 2022 we should be
more capable Canada of sharing and
to use this important information
for governments but what is more
strategic what is more
important is the important for
healthcare workers for
patients who need to have access to
this individual information rather
than  use faxes or pieces of
paper to be able to ensure that people
receive quality and
safe care so it is part
of a big agenda for vaccines for
example in Ontar  io there is not yet
it's not fair in Ontario it's the
same across the country there is no
system for children by chance for
example no system that allows us
to connect the nurses the
doctors the access technicians
to find out if a child is vaccinated and
a child arrives at the emergency room
at the hospital then the nurse or the
doctor is not able to know if
that child is vaccinated  because
in 2022 we don't have the technology to
share this information at the
patient level and at the worker level, that's
the big issue we hear we talked about,
among other things, before covered a
few weeks ago
of rigor in the  collection of
monies what do you respond to the
general income verification a huge magnet of rigor
in the work she does we saw it
then I mentioned it during the covid
we were there to help the  people then
we really saved lives this
weekend I was still on the te  rrain I
met entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs who told me there if you
hadn't been there I could I
won't be here to talk to you
today so we saved jobs
we saved people we saved
families and I'm convinced  that each
of you here had
parents from the families of people you
know who have been struggling
with covid
open those monies there as effectively
as having given them in the first
in the first case eventually
watch the tps the  work the
verification work has started the letters
have been sent to you we will do it on a case-
by-case basis we will really support the
Canadians we say there will be no
penalty there will be no interest we want to
recover the sums we will recover  the
sums
says that this is the current plan it is
not sufficient she asks for a more
exhaustive plan to carry out
more extensive verifications than those which are already
planned so do you  lez
present a new plan listen we have
a plan for me then with the agency with
the discussions we had we have a good
plan we are working with the population we are
working with the people this work we
say is several years old but the  work
is well underway and with the companies
the work had started a year before
the verifications with the PCU the
companies are collaborating well why
we have it before I mentioned it must
be remembered there that in 2020 when the
covid arrived the season  tax
ended on September 30 there
was data that we did not have
at that time then after September 37 5
months later we were in the other
tax season so there is a lot
of work that is  is done by the agency
we don't give them we work with our
people we hired but we will be there
to support the Canadians then I
tell you the covid is not over
on the plan that the
general audit asks for it asks for a better
audit plan than the ones that are already
done than those that are already planned
there you say you defend your plan
you defend the work of your
employees the Revenue Agency so do
we have to understand that you refuse
that it  there is a review of the current plan
it is that we will look at the plan then
in the discussions we will see
discussions with the
general audit to also be able with her
what is she how she sees
that we  could improve the plan
I would also like to have these ideas it is
for it improved material there is
always material to do better but I
can tell you one thing if we had to
start over what happened I will
do it again and  government I will do
exactly the same thing the same
programs
to save lives then in the
meetings I have with people in
the community whether it is with groups
who work volunteers who
help people at the corporate level at
the whole level  fortunately everyone tells me
that it was not the Conservatives who
were in power so I am very
proud of the work that was done, madam
general bottle
, calculated from the GST,
saying there are companies that did
not meet the criteria if  we
analyze their GST results they are no longer
eligible for the subsidy
we have helped our companies we have maintained
employment links between employees and
employers we are the country that is the
best that is best organized at the
level  of the economic recovery then
as I say I am very proud of the
work that was done
you do not want to say whether or not
you checked the TP